bien alors on va passer à un autre
couple alors vraiment vraiment
particulier c'est moi qu'on puisse dire
c'est paul léautaud avec marie dormoy
alors présenté nous ce ce couple moment
où ils vont
je dois préciser avant de parler de ce
couple que cette publication est faite à
la demande de l'exécuteur testamentaire
l'été marie dormoy renommée dont on
n'est pas dans un autre officiel ici
comme vous faites par déclaration
officielle on va y venir poser la
question que je me posais des questions
après on verra bien mais il faut que les
gens comprennent d'abord apprendre à
pourquoi accepter peut-être oseo risqué
de publier mais moi j'aurais d'abord non
représentés nous et de personnages tout
le monde ne connaît pas les autos et
marie dormoy alors les autant il a quel
âge les autos à cette époque à 61 ans
et lorsqu'il rencontre marie elle est
bibliothécaire à la bibliothèque jacques
bosser et elle a quarante six ans
les autos et frustré dans ses amours
marielle de son côté est très
malheureuse
elle achève une liaison avec leur shit
est qd auguste perret et lorsqu'ils se
rencontrent en 1933
contrairement à ce qu'on pourrait croire
ce n'est pas l'exposition d'amour
les autos découvre une femme d'abord
qu'il n'aime pas et il commence un
journal un journal intime qui est
d'ailleurs une branche annexe du journal
littéraire dans laquelle il consigne au
jour le jour l'évolution de cette
liaison qui est il faut le dire une
dix ans érotique mais vous dites même
dans la présentation de ce journal vous
dit que c'est un que c'est purement et
simplement journal observe non je n'ai
pas dit que c'était un journal obscène
c'est un journal qui a des qui a
peut-être des côtes et obscène et il ne
faut pas oublier qu'au fur et à mesure
qu'on avance dans cette liaison
les retours de couvre la moins vous lire
la traduction c'est page 10 voici le
paragraphe
car c'est d'abord un journal obscène que
le lecteur va découvrir dissimulé au
coeur du journal intime alors désolé
mais si oui pouvez pas dire à votre
préface à l'obscène et puis après ici
dire que ça ne l'est pas oui c'est un
journal obscène c'est vrai parce que le
langage de léautaud à une
certaines vulgarités c'est le langage
que l'on utilisait peut-être c'est un
langage populaire et souvent militaire
car il part à l'assaut de marie et
lorsqu il la découvre il dit d'abord
qu'il voit un gros boudin qu'elle n'a
pas de taille qu'il est aussi grosse en
haut qu'en bas qu'elle n'a pas la bouche
fait pour certains exercices c'est le
vocabulaire de léautaud elle ne s'épile
pas là où il aime que les fans c'est
pile et puis elle ne s'est pas prononcé
des mots polis sont au bon moment parce
que les autos en a besoin pour dit-il se
mettre en position et c'est un
déchaînement de d'agressions physiques
contre le corps de marley elle n'est pas
belle c'est triste à dire pas du tout
joli de visage elle est depuis ce
horriblement fait pas de taille pas de
hanches pas de krupp aussi grosse ans au
camp bin gros boudin par dessus le
marché une peau une carnation affreuse
je ne suis pas fier de ma complète ses
pieds battent c'est absolument effrayant
si effrayant oui et le journal que le va
s'appliquer à découvrir petit à petit la
la beauté cachée de cette femme alors
pourquoi d'abord lui s'est dit elle
parce que en suisse est pour deux
raisons d'abord elle-même et malheureuse
elle a perdu elles étaient obligées
d'avorter plusieurs fois d'un amant
qu'elle est mais je viens d'en parler
d'auguste perret elle est une écrivain
plus ou moins raté l envie d'aimer mais
d'aimer maternellement et puis elle est
curieuse du journal littéraire que les
autos tiens j'ai d'ailleurs consacré une
étude longue à 7
parti pour glisser pour obtenir le
manuscrit du journal je pense que c'est
pour le sauver des de tous les rapaces
qui rêvent de se l'approprier
oui mais quel ton veut le faire acheter
des trains les autorités prêt à le
vendre n'importe quel collectionneurs
pour entretenir sa ménagerie
à cette époque il avait peut-être 35 à
45 chats et deux à quinze le chien
bientôt ça va coûter cher la vie qu'il
avait au mercure de france n'est plus à
porter ça c'est d'article c'est pas
donné à lui tout simplement parce que 10
c'est le seul moyen pour moi de savoir
si un jour ce jour là vous êtes un peu
dure a fait marrer mais normalement je
suis pas dire mais moi je voulais mari
accepte à tous dès le premier jour même
je vous cite l'odeur âcre sur de sueur
et de l'âge mal la baie qui s'échappa du
pantalon son nouvel amant écrira-t-elle
témoin je suis vraiment rien ces bons
qui écrivait alors je me dis mais
pourquoi at elle cédé je crois que est
là il y a plusieurs choses qui l'ont
poussé c'est d'abord cette grande
solitude elle le dit dans ses mémoires
il ya trente pages qui concerne les
autos et elle dit que l avais envie de
de s'approcher de ce vieil homme pense
au journal littéraire mais aussi pour
son immense solitude et lui alors
pourquoi elle c'était sa conquête alors
qu'il la trouve l aide affreuse parce
que les autos mène toujours plusieurs
affaires à la fois et contrairement à ce
qu'il écrivait dans ses aphorismes les
autos à une maîtresse officielle c'est
anne crayssac
c'est elle qui lui fait les petits plats
entre 12h et 15h et en même temps c'est
celle acquise va faire une petite
minette ni et 12h et 15h quand il sort
du mercure de ce qu'il appelle le fléau
alors ils l'appellent le fléau la
panthère moore
monde ma chère chaire est
adorable qu madame jamais and queyssac
ce sont des rapports qui sont alors là
on peut parler d' obscénité
vous êtes d'un érotisme forcené et
d'ailleurs on peut on peut juger les
lettres qu'il a écrites à marie en
lisant la correspondance générale
vous en avez un bel exemple elle a été
publié en 1972
mais justement je ne veux pas que vous
tiriez mari de ce côté il faut il ne
faut pas oublier que marie c'est une
femme de lettres cultivée intelligente
sensible qui petit à petit va elle aussi
en quelque sorte tombée amoureuse de
léautaud qui va se laisser fasciner par
les autos et les autos lui vint tombé
amoureux de ma rue émile le trouve pas
mal à la femme et à la mauvaise image du
rassemblement ont été détruites non ce
n'est pas vrai c'est incroyable de voir
apparaître sous la loupe puisque j'ai
travaillé avec une loupe pour décrypter
ce point de mériter la surface est
illisible j'avais une heure pour
décrypter une page on voit apparaître
les mots de la tendresse dans ce journal
les autos n'a jamais de sa vie prononcer
le mot ma chérie nous on chérit il n'a
jamais dit un mot tendre de sa vie si
quand on pense que les autos est un
enfant abandonné qui disait à l'âge de 7
ans que les cv à sa mère ma chère madame
cher madame c'est tout ce qu'il a connu
de sa mère l'a 30 ans quand il a sorti
la rencontre et il a osé dû écrire des
lettres d'amour et en un an toutes
tailles tout cet amour de l'amour il a
enfermé dans une forteresse l'espèce
d'égoïsme c'est cynique bon sens qui est
une pure tuerie de l'amour puisqu'il
peut le perturber les frais et la beauté
de cette chose lorsque ce sont deux
beautés je veux dire ce petit bout c'est
que ça cherche pas à faire des grâces
système de croquis cynique comme ça bon
et donc c'est pas tellement audacieux ce
qu'il dit je
ve je vais je brevets parce qu'il
faisait alors que je n'y allais faut
qu'il dit je veux blanc c'était pas si
bizarre les pratiques audacieux mais
françois nous ici vous avez connu
léautaud
non je n'ai pas connu léautaud mais j'ai
rencontré marie dans moi alors j'ai
rencontré marie dormoy en cinquante deux
parce que j'avais une drôle de petit
prix qui s'appelle briefé néons polo
grise pour l'eau grise qui était géré
par l'université et dans marie dormoy
était la secrétaire et on m'a dit
paulhan paulhan m'a dit il faut
absolument aller voir marie dormoy vous
verrez c'est quelqu'un de c'est
quelqu'un de passionnant alors je suis
allé dans le fameux bureau de la
bibliothèque sainte-geneviève
je me suis trouvé devant une dame que
tout le monde dit grande moi j'ai pas
souvenir d'une dalle de grandes
c'étaient les épinards
je vais pas me battre et était plus
large que grand oncle et autour de les
laver avant le genre le genre adrienne
monnier vous savez j'en robe de bure
enfin en 52 ans 50 de l'etrat ce n'était
pas évident c'était une personne d'une
grande culture lettrée sinueuse très
charmant saviez toutes ces choses là
c'était non pourquoi
alors qu'est-ce que ça tout à l'heure je
vous ai dit je vous ai dit je trouve un
peu de chénerilles dans ce manuscrit
parce que tout d'un coup j'ai collé les
mots à l'image de cette vieille dame
c'est ça devient un peu gênant ça
devient gênant c'est un peu gênant alors
robert malley bien connu léautaud et qui
a fait des entretiens et inoubliable
avec lui devait avec vous présenter ce
journal particulier mais il m'a dit au
téléphone
ah non je ne peux pas venir et il m'a
dit je ne peux pas parce que je suis
contre la publication de ce journal
non pas du tout par prix de ris se passa
mais tout simplement je trouve ça
n'ajoute rien à la gloire de léautaud et
de marie dormoy
au contraire même sais c'est pas bien du
tout et il trouve cette mauvaise action
que ce journal c'est une alors robert
mallet serait d'accord pour qu'on brûle
ce journal est c'est une branche annexe
du journal littéraire si robert malley
l'avez lu il verrait 5 juin 1933 voir
journal courant c'est un fragment du
journal littéraire que les autos appelé
aussi communément journal général ou
journal courant alors je ne vois pas
pourquoi on exercerait une censure à
propos de ce journal qui est la partie
la plus intime la plus retirés de
l'homme donnait la coque mais marie
dormoy qui appartenait à marie dormoy
laquelle l'a remis à l'exécuteur
testamentaire exécuteurs testamentaires
monsieur etienne buteau qui est
magistrat à la cour d'appel de poitiers
magistrat honoraire maintenant et qui
m'a demandé pour achever et finir le
travail que j'avais fait sur les autos
et le mercure de france de bien vouloir
décrypter ce journal parce que il faut
s'y atteler à ce décryptage l'introduire
et l'a noté ce que j'ai fait je le
consacre donc des heures et des heures à
ce travail comme il se doit et vous avez
été scandalisée par ce que j'ai lu m'a
rejeté
moi je n'ai fait disons que j'ai jamais
passé
ma vigne et mes études à lire des
journaux ou même des romans érotiques
j'ai été extrêmement surprise imaginez
que je travaille avec une grosse loupe
puisqu'on ne peut pas lire ce roman oui
et quand on m'a remis ces boîtiers
hermétiquement fermé qui sont fermés
depuis peut-être vingt ans j'ai ouvert
et j'ai je suis allée acheter une loupe
ne pouvons rien faire rien deviner rien
comprendre
j'ai commencé à lui à lire sais tu pas
possible ce que je lisais le croyait
mais au fur et à mesure je les ai vu
apparaître les mots de la tendresse et
l'a aidé à mon coeur a battu mahut sémou
de tendresse ou lauriers que l'hypoxie
gégory canal publié par honnêteté parce
que c'est les autres alors franchement
il fallait il publier
de toute façon l'idée qu'on puisse
détruire occulter ou brûlés latex après
la mort à l'écrit maintenant c'est
monstrueux
un écrivain doit prendre ses précautions
et très tôt et faire disparaître ce
qu'ils estiment devoir disparaître
cela dit les héritiers qui empêche qu'on
publie les inédits et tout ça c'est
scandaleux
donc je crois là vous avez puis vous
avez raison et non des vallées les
honteuses qui lui tend son journal mais
qu il nous renvoie lui même à son
journal littéraire parce qu'il soit né
sait bien les autos même si vous ne
l'avez pas pas connu oui c'est
simplement comment expliquez-vous que il
nous raconte tout dans ce dans ce genre
particulier c'est raté
temps en temps avec marie dormoy temps
en temps il y des notes tous ses organes
les fans de tout ça mais pourquoi pas
qui est ce qui explique sony l'alerté
stendhalien écouter les plus grands se
prononce d'autre part des fiascos
oui on le voir rater à terre rattes
hélas et où tout commence par un beau
fiasco cours de la nuit féminité de la
junte pendant mille ans mais bourgoin et
pendant des heures est alors après
l'hymne jetons fatigué maintenant je ne
peux plus passer à l'action alors
seulement si fait ça par altruisme ou
bien s'il fait ça parce qu'ils vécurent
c'est par ce titre qui est altruiste
présidence au sein du pdl alors de
mentir c'est la tête de la psychiatrie
en ce qui concerne et aux séquences
amené hauts et les bas de léautaud
les facultés pour demander ou pas écouté
il y a des eaux dont il se vante d eau
de deux heures qui sont à saverdun du
coup même avec un peu de méfiance et si
je pense qu'il a un côté piquant vie et
dans vit bien
alors voila si en face c'était bon alors
vous êtes mesdames vous étiez karine
mériaux vous n'avez pas dit l'avocat on
vous allez par louise labé qu'est-ce que
vous fallait publier ce journal ou pas
ah oui je pense tout à fait que c'est un
document je ne dirais pas que j'en fais
mes délices quotidien parce que j'ai
j'éprouve certaines difficultés à lire
ce genre de littérature mais je trouve
ça tout à fait nécessaire et important
que l'on ait un témoignage de cette
nature sur le la difficulté d'aimer et
sur la solitude de l'égoïste qui ne
l'est peut être pas par naissance qu'il
est sans doute par par circonstances et
je crois qu'il ya un retournement de la
de la détresse certain moment dans
l'excès même dans la dans la violence de
cette haine de cette obstination qui est
qui presque enfin je pourrais pourrait
s'ouvrir sur sur son contraire enfin j'y
vois une certaine forme d'amour dans
dans l'acharnement qui s'ouvre sur son
contraire car les autos t'en vas moureu
à 61 ans on peut le souhaiter à beaucoup
oui pas de tomber amoureux de cette
manière un ânon mes 60 ans un
allongement salée mais il ya beaucoup
d'hommes que 60 ans s'imagine pas prêt d
auto démarre à 60 ans est aussi une
éducation châtiment pour démarrer des
moeurs aurait pris part pas au regard de
tous alors patrick grainville